okay so let's you know let's take you
through this so you got a hand job at a
happy ending yeah
you said you're going to put this out of
your mind obviously
did you go back for more no no i never
went back never went back never did it
again so it was all based on this one
infinite
but the pornography still still came
still was in my life like that was a
thing that i had that i just could not
break it was like why is porn why is
porn bad i think a lot of people would
listen it's okay to watch porn you're
just watching it and it's entertaining
and it's could be satisfying why is that
bad well this is the thing um well first
of all if your wife is fine with it then
there you go you know what i mean i i
guess it wouldn't be bad but the problem
was i i kept it from her because she
didn't like it
and if she would agree then it would
have been cool
but she didn't like it and how do you
know she didn't know because she let me
know she didn't like it and that's one
reason why you said it was a secret well
but this is the thing i mean there were
times when she she would walk
caught me or whatever and she's like you
are you in that oh no no i was just
seeing what was going on you know it was
just me and whenever you know
i was like
like a 15 year old being caught by their
mom oh yeah it was a grown-ass man like
i'm like oh i i just i can't believe
people are having sex on the internet
you know
but this is the thing though and that's
that's the thing it's kind of like my my
big deal was
it started to change and this is where
you you go into it because again a lot
of people say there's nothing wrong with
it but i know for me
for me it started to change the way i
saw people like people did they lost
their humanity like people became
objects like
it
it felt like i was just connected and
and i have to tell you
in general or just the people that you
are watching in no just every i like
when i say that i i i it means that
you know it's kind of like you're
i have to say whatever you think about
it kind of manifests in different ways
you know what i mean like i saw women as
less than me
you know what i mean i i saw women as oh
yeah yeah you know she's probably you
know it's kind of weird because
the mindset was
just because i was a man that i was more
valuable than the women in my life
simply because that's what everything
told me and when i looked at and porn in
itself
it's one of those things where like i
remember going to a strip club with with
uh football players and you know the the
girls up on stage and the whole thing
and then if she comes down and wants to
talk to the players it's like stop stop
talking to us
because you're like becoming human you
know what i mean like you're i want you
to go back up there and be a picture be
an image be
just be a doll but any bit of humanity
was is off-putting
and i started to treat
people like that treat everyone in my
life like that i saw how this was
changing me
what was wild is that
pornography
was it took me out of all that
it was like oh like i didn't drink i
didn't smoke but that was one of them
things like oh my god how did you get in
there
dude i was at i was my flute lessons my
food lessons wait wait wait all right
i know let
no i would go over my uncle's house my
uncle was a jazz musician
and he played the saxophone in the flute
and that's who's who taught me but he
was really uh you know he would he would
he was a jazz guy so he would get high
he had like is this your mother's
brother this was my
actually my aunt's husband okay so he
was uh
by marriage by marriage and he but he
would get high and he was all into
everything like he had the zodiac
calendar with all the sexual positions
and i'd be walking and i'm like wow you
know how old were you oh i was probably
nine years old oh [ __ ] um and
he also had a huge chest full of every
brand of porn like you know player
penthouse
we playboy all the hustler everything
and what would happen is i would do the
lesson and then i'd have to wait for my
mother to pick me up and he'd lead me
down there reading and i ope i found it
kids were always fine this is another
thing too people say you know nothing
wrong with porn if you're over 18
but i don't know anybody who ever
discovered pornography at 18 no you know
you're always a child you know somehow
and
and this is where it it it kind of
messed me up because i was too young
and those images and this and the
position that i was in
just
in my home life
it beca it's changed something in my
brain you know like i know there was
something that happened where i was like
this i'm hooked because dude when i
opened that magazine i was like holy cow
i was gone like it was like a high and i
was like they're so beautiful
look at these women now i didn't even
know what sex was
[Music]